hello and welcome to the very first
episode of dear Hank and John or as I
like to think of it Dear John and a Hank
we are John and Hank green and this
podcast is where we what do we do here
Hank this is the podcast where we answer
your questions we're going to provide
some dubious advice that we are not
qualified to give and also give you all
the week's news from both Mars the
planet and AFC Wimbledon the 18th tier
English soccer club but first John how
about a very short poem for today fourth
fourth tier for the record but ok we're
going to start with a Langston Hughes
poem for today folks
I'm telling you birthing is hard and
dying is mean so get yourself a little
lovin in between that brings us nicely
Hank to today's first question which is
from Lindy she writes a Dear John and
Hank hey so there's this girl I really
really like maybe even love I don't know
this is confusing I have felt like this
for six years but the problem is that I
am also a girl and she is straight how
do I stop liking them as more than a
friend John I just want to say thank you
so much for starting us off with the
hardest question ever how do you stop
loving a person John yep not my area of
expertise my area of expertise is
continuing to love someone even when
it's a bad idea mmm mm-hmm I thought
this was more of a question for Hank
this seems like something that Hank
would be good at uh right well uh just
just if you say so bury yourself in
other things just get really obsessed
with bowling and just think like take
all the energy that you're focusing on
this lovely person and focus it on
getting to being a really good bowler or
or you know probably something more
useful than bowling would be a good idea
Hank do you know that that's literally
what I did my senior year of college are
you aware of that or was that did you
just come up with bowling ray no no I
looked over and I was like I have to
find something and I saw my bowling pin
that I was
for getting I got a $1.99 that day and
and so I won this bowling pin as a
trophy and that's what I saw so that's
what I that's what I hit I I was in a
long-term relationship that that ended
and I was still very much in love with
this young woman that I was in a
relationship with and one of the things
that I took up in the wake of the
relationship was bowling and I became an
extremely passionate bowler I bowled
every single day by myself at the
bowling alley in Mount Vernon Ohio and I
just loved it it was a wonderful release
for me it was repetitious in a way that
soothed my brain I'm a huge fan of
bowling and when you call bowling
useless as I believe you just did it
hurts me it hurts me deep down I just I
mean if you're gonna if you're gonna
spend 500 hours getting over someone
which is at least as long as it takes
you might want to focus on like maybe
something like playing guitar or
accordion or maybe learning uh
theoretical physics I don't know bowling
comes in handy I definitely go bowling
and when I go bowling and someone's
really good at bowling I'm like yeah
you're really good at bowling and I
think that about them so it's not like
completely useless
uh it's as useless as being good at any
other sport except that it's better
because bowling is something that
everyone can enjoy together
even if you're not bowling I feel like
you and Joe enjoy bowling just as much
as people who are if I go to the bowling
alley I'm like my shoulder hurts which
it does sometimes and I don't Bowl I
still have a good time because bowling
is really more about sitting around so
Indy I think I think we've arrived upon
a solution for you um it's not easy to
change your feelings about someone or to
wait out your feelings about someone or
to sublimate them but the key is bowling
you're welcome God we're so good at
advice um this one is from Lucas Dear
John and Hank what is your favorite
thing to look at in the night sky well
yeah there's a lot to choose one I think
I'm gonna cop like over the cop-out
answer here and say the Milky Way
because if you can see it would you
can't always in a lot of the country but
in here in Montana we often can if you
can see the Milky Way it is the
most amazing awe-inspiring like
tear-inducing put you in your placing
thing that you can see it's a really
beautiful thing and it's a really
beautiful experience to like really look
at the galaxy and be like there it is
and I can only see it in that direction
which means that we're sitting out here
on the edge of it and it's a big
beautiful thing I think that that is
that is by far the most sort of
beautiful thing you can see in the night
sky with your naked eye of course it's
I'm saying it's a cop-out because it is
not a thing it is many billion things
for me it's uh the the middle star in
Orion's belt what I like to think of as
Orion's belt buckle that's my favorite
thing to look at as a very fancy answer
Hank but I like Orion's belt buckle it
just uh it reminds me of where I am in
the world that star is called Anna lamb
and it is a super blue supergiant which
is a big a big star ah and it is only a
one thousand three hundred and forty
light-years away John and yes I did just
let that up on Wikipedia quick question
about blue giant stars are they about to
die like what is what it what are the
chances that I'm going to stop enjoying
Orion's belt buckle because it turns
into a supernova um I think that you're
safe for your lifetime what about like
young people watching this podcast uh or
or listening to it I don't know offhand
about the average age of a blue
supergiant but in general the lifetime
of a human is not consequential ah the
lifetime of a human is not consequential
you really one really does come here to
get the good news um do you have a
question I do dear Hank and John uh this
is from Claire I graduated from high
school three days ago and next year I'm
going to a very prestigious university
well thanks for letting us know how
prestigious your university is Claire
this is good
she says I'm very happy that the black
magic of College Admissions somehow spun
in my favor but this school it is
expensive and has lots of amazing
resources across the board from
Janee ring to the arts and back I just
want to milk my 32 courses for all
they're worth so I'm curious what do you
guys think what should I study to be the
biggest help to the world please assume
for the sake of argument that I'm
equally good at all academic disciplines
which while untrue is my rhetorical
stance that is a fascinating question
I think Claire is is is in for big
things no matter what she does given the
quality of her question asking um I'm
interested in know what you think Hank
I'm super into the idea of having a
really diverse base of knowledge so if
you got 32 classes you know you're gonna
have to focus on something because they
require you to major in things in
college but do your best to have a broad
abroad experience and like as long as
everything that you're taking is in some
way challenging um so it like that's
that's what you want you want to be
challenged and you want to not hate your
life so that's what you should try and
do with college and everything else yeah
and your entire life I have a huge Roger
Ebert fan Hank the great film critic who
is also something of a public
intellectual like he wasn't he studied
film and write you know wrote film
reviews for most of his career but he
also studied a lot of other things and
had a lot of other fields that he found
interesting and I thought that idea like
I feel like that idea of the public
intellectual has sort of fallen away in
this era of specialization and there's
there are great things about
specialization but I completely agree
with you when you specialize in
unexpected ways when you have unexpected
when you can make unexpected connections
between worlds that people think of as
separate that really makes you stand out
so I think that's the that's the best of
what higher education has to offer now
and I totally agree that Claire should
embrace that and we have another
question this is from Ava Dear John and
Hank will you come to our wedding in
British Columbia on July 11th Ava let me
just answer before Hank does because
Hank lives very close to British
Columbia not at all inconvenient to him
he has no children I can't see a reason
why he wouldn't go unless he's just a
jerk but I can't go because I will be
supporting the
the adaptation of my book Paper Towns
and I have previous commitments I'm so
sorry Ava but I'm sure that Hank is
gonna say yes i doing colonoscopy prep
that day so wow that's actually a
fantastic excuse yeah I got a got a
drink a bunch of awful snot that makes
me turn into a poop volcano is one high
quality excuse for not attending a
wedding congratulations and
congratulations to you as well Ava we
will send a gift with help me with I
think this is the gift no no no will
send a gift we'll get them something she
didn't even tell us where she was
registered I don't feel like I got a
formal invitation you know she just
emailed Hank and John at gmail.com I did
there was nothing letterpressed I don't
I don't like to criticize people's
wedding invitation strategies because
certainly I think the wedding industry
is a bit bloated but I mean you know you
could have sent something in the mail
Ava okay here's another question this
one is from Sam Sam says dear Hank and
John do you guys have faith that humans
will eventually colonize the galaxy no I
can answer that in one word no I do not
think that we will ever colonize the
galaxy the galaxy is very fun other
stars are so far away I I was really
interested to hear your answer to this
question John because I didn't I
honestly didn't know which way you were
gonna go I think we already have what
just a very small part of the galaxy
do colonize do you mean Earth and Mars
no I mean earth just earth we have done
an amazing job of colonizing earth I
mean we we've colonized only sprang out
of earth there is a hardly a square inch
of this planet that humans have not
either lived in or peed in definitely
well humans have peed on every single
part of the planet definitely know there
is it yeah you can't find us everywhere
on this planet but you can find our
waste everywhere I actually be
interested to see a map of where humans
haven't peed I bet there's some places I
mean there's certainly some places in
Antarctica and maybe the Sahara where
humans haven't peed
there's large swaths of the ocean where
we haven't peed but I would argue that
our pee is filtered out into the rest of
the ocean I mean if you pee oh certainly
once you pee in the ocean we've once you
feed in the entire ocean yeah so if
you've peed in the Atlantic you by the
law of transitive ocean ping you've also
peed in the Pacific because it's all
connected it's really just one body of
water that we have named various oceans
so you've peed in the one human the one
earth ocean really if you've peed in any
body of water that's gonna if you've
peed in a river you've beat in the ocean
now this is getting pretty meta Hank but
it when I peed in the white river I
technically peed in the in the Indian
Ocean here's a question for you if you
peed in the white river
did you pee into a cloud oh because
eventually that water that was in your
pee is some of its gonna end up in
clouds not just in clouds Hank but also
it's going to end up in rain that's
gonna end up falling on Antarctica do
does it rain there I don't know it's the
question is did you pee on your own head
I thought more concerned with whether I
whether I have successfully peed on all
seven continents and you refuse to
answer that because you also don't know
if it rains in Antarctica Sam if we can
zoom out of your question a little bit
if you're referring to us colonizing non
solar system things
there's no way in ten thousand years we
could even get to another planetary it's
just it's it's not possible
unfortunately it would be awesome I love
Star Trek it's just not possible
my serious answer to Sam is that in
10,000 years no in a hundred thousand
years I don't know in a million years if
humans are still around we may have
found ways to inhabit other star systems
it is it would be a very slow process
unless some kind of faster than light
travel was developed in which case more
power to us but I feel like if faster
than light travel was possible we would
have seen aliens by now
let me just back up and and respond to a
different part of that which is your
proposal that human beings might exist
in a million years which is ludicrous of
all the things of all the ridiculous
things involved in colonizing other
stars in the galaxy the part where we
still have humans in a million years is
the most ridiculous
are you saying million or billion
million with an M I completely disagree
with you it is entirely possible that
there will still be humans in a million
years I mean why would you why would I
will bet you $100 right now that there
will be no humans in a million years uh
I take the bet all right
I can't lose I'm not gonna lose there is
we we are lucky if we have five thousand
years our species is insane it's in the
greed the consumption the the mutually
assured self-destruction oh we are in
the second half of being people for sure
for sure I well even if we are in the
second I know we might have might have
up to a hundred thousand years at the
very the very best that could happen
hundred thousand years there's a there's
a lot there's a lot of potential future
but there are also many many species
that have been around for longer than a
million years they may not be anywh in
any way like us right yeah I don't know
that's like saying like this rock is
really old so I bet I'll live forever -
all right I I think I I think that the
future is unknowable why don't you why
don't you ask the next question dear
Hank and John what if a guy says I'm too
smart for him this question came from
Rebecca here's my advice Rebecca so I
want you to go to a mirror find a mirror
somewhere and then um I always find it
helpful to practice my faces in the
mirror Hank do you know what I mean like
I just try to surprise so that I know
what people are seeing when I make a
face that if I'm trying to communicate
an emotion with my face I want them to I
want to know what they're seeing you
know like what my happy face looks like
etc uh-huh so Rebecca I want you to go
to a mirror I want you to I want you to
put on a face of horror
like I like just horrified and then I
want you to like slightly transfigure
that face to add in intense disgust and
then I want you to hold on to that face
figure out what it looks like and the
next time someone tells you that that
that you are too smart for them I want
you to make that face and then I want
you to say no no no no no no you are no
longer under consideration and then back
away and move on with your life take a
bowling take a bowling I I think the the
answer to that question or the response
to you're too smart for me is uh yeah I
think you're right
I'm glad that we're on the same page
about this I didn't know that I was too
smart for you until just now but thank
you for confirming it thanks for thanks
for letting me know Hank we only have we
only have time in this first podcast for
one more question
um it comes from a g'day I hope I said
your name right egged a Dear John and
Hank I really like what you guys do on
YouTube
I was just wondering who does your
parents think is the better son no oh
wow that's easy is it like well let's
just let's just answer on three okay
we'll answer together that way your
opinion won't shape mine or anything
we'll just answer on three okay one two
three day no you are cheating that's not
that's total cheating I stayed true to
the rules of the game that I invented
and you cheated typical I just think
that my parents really like Dave they do
like Dave oh I think it's time for the
news from Mars which is saying a small
planet on the edge of the Milky Way
galaxy and the news from AFC Wimbledon
which is the most important soccer team
in the history of the world that's what
we do at the end of the podcast John why
do we do it well because you of Mars I
love AFC Wimbledon and people love to
learn about Mars and AFC Wimbledon this
week NASA is testing the low-density
supersonic decelerating system which is
also called the
DSD because God forbid NASA makes
something without having an appropriate
acronym well you got it right it's a lot
of words you gotta have a fast way to
write it down so the LDS DS job is to
deliver larger payloads than we can
currently deliver to the surface of Mars
there's this problem that you have when
you're traveling interplanetary ly that
you are going very fast when you arrive
at your destination and you have to slow
down and it is difficult to slow down so
one of the things that they do to slow
down is they just hit the atmosphere and
let the atmosphere slow the craft down
and then eventually open parachutes and
the parachutes will further slow the
craft down and then like at the last
moment you fire some Rockets may be a
problem that Mars has is that there
isn't a ton of air in the atmosphere so
parachutes won't open higher in the
atmosphere so you can't slow down as
fast as you would like especially if
your craft is super heavy the job of the
ldsd is to it basically inflates to make
the craft bigger it's like a bunch of
balloons like airbags on the side of the
craft that that catch the atmosphere
increase its surface area so it can slow
down faster before deploying the
parachutes and that increases the
payloads we can deliver to Mars from
like one and a half tons to up to three
tons which is twice as much very
exciting so I just want to confirm Hank
that the most interesting thing that
happened on Mars this week happened on
earth well that is almost always gonna
be the case it's gonna be more news in
Mars and regarding Mars when Hank and I
initially came up with the idea for this
podcast we were like oh and we'll do the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon and
then a Hank literally said to me but is
there news from AFC Wimbledon every week
and I'm like is there news from Mars
every week I like I just don't
understand yours your prep your
proposition that somehow AFC Wimbledon
and Mars are on the same plane of
interest I mean no I listen to be clear
I am not proposing that AFC Wimbledon
and Mars are on the same plane I am
proposing that AFC Wimbledon is in fact
far more important
than Mars yeah I have a really hard time
with this I mean if you look at the
amount of like attention and money spent
on one of those two things much more
attention and money you spent on Mars I
like this is a true fact
Mars is a cold dead Rock much like any
of the gajillions of cold dead rocks
scattered throughout the universe not
only that but you can find you can find
cold dead rocks right here on earth you
don't have to go to space to get one
however you do have to go to South
London to get AFC Wimbledon so can we
get to instead of arguing about whether
Mars is more interesting than AFC
Wimbledon which is a settled question
because AFC Wimbledon is more
interesting can we get to the news from
AFC Wimbledon this week that is
acceptable
okay Hank so AFC Wimbledon the fourth
tier English soccer team that plays in
South London has three on the uniform
spots for sponsorship right there's the
front of shirt there's the back of the
shirt and then there's the back of the
shorts you know what I'm talking about
yeah yeah yeah so like you got like a
corporate name on each of those places
so Hank can you guess what savvy
marketing oriented corporation will be
advertising itself on the lower left
buttock of next season's AFC Wimbledon
uniform is in you guess is it uh dftba
records it's us that's right it is us
they're shorts will again say dftba
nerdfighteria right there in that
wonderful liminal space between left
thigh and left buttock i am so excited
to be able to announce this week that
the 2015-2016 AFC wimbledon uniform will
again remind its players and opponents
who are running behind its players not
to forget to be awesome I'm very excited
the season is over for AFC Wimbledon but
of course the news AFC Wimbledon wise
continues year round so we'll have
plenty to discuss in this exciting
offseason as AFC Wimbledon attempts to
strengthen their squad to really push up
to maybe next year make it to the third
tier of English football um and as I'm
going to attempt to feign interest in
your weird interests
are they doing these days John well hang
because I just told you the season has
ended so they aren't currently playing
but how do they how did they do how did
they do how did they do okay you dude do
you never look to see how they're doing
what do you do all day like I don't
understand what you look at on the
internet if you aren't looking at least
occasionally at soccer standings in
fourth tier English football like what
is it on the internet that you look at
instead Mars stuff yeah um
they finish 15th in Ligue 2 this year so
called because it's the 4th League of
English football it goes the Premier
League than the championship then Ligue
1 then League Two and then you aren't in
the the league anymore you're not a
professional team so you want to stay at
least in Ligue 2 so they finished 15th
and League two comfortably mid-table but
next season will be looking to really
push toward the top half of that table
and maybe even into the top few spots
that get up to Ligue 1 this sounds
complicated John not as complicated as
building a thing to go on Mars the size
of a minivan yeah yeah and also not as
cool yeah so what did we learn today
Hank we learned that that love is hard
and that we're not going to go to Ava's
wedding yep we also learned that we're
probably not going to go to colonize
other stars in the galaxy and we learned
that while love is hard and it's hard to
move on from love there is always what
Emily Dickinson's so beautifully called
hope that that thing with feathers which
today comes in the form of bowling the
human lifespan is insignificant thanks
for listening
to dear Hank and John or as I like to
think of it Dear John and Hank you can
email us your questions and problems and
anything else that you want to email us
at Hank and John at gmail.com obviously
Hank registered that email address but
thanks again for listening and as we say
in our hometown of nerdfighteria don't
forget to be awesome
you